thanks everyone
so like led yard is something that I'm
pretty passionate about three years or
so for various festivals and things of
that nature and so it's something that I
just kind of want to talk to you all
about six I think there's a lot of cool
stuff here by the way I have a lot of
resources to go along with this talk you
can find it at the URL at the bottom of
this slide and don't worry this URL will
also be on the side of most of the other
slides in the presentation
so like led yard is something that I
find really fascinating in a lot of ways
because it really is a hybrid of
technology specifically technology that
we already tend to know and art and I
think there's a lot of misconceptions
about what art really is you know we
tend to think of it as this world that's
just completely separate from technology
we kind of view them as having no
overlap whatsoever but I don't think
that's true I think there's actually
quite a bit of overlap cuz I really dig
into it art is quite technical when you
look at it we just don't see that or
think about it but it really is you know
for example have you ever looked at how
paints actually work you know we often
think of painting as one of these sort
of classic arts and we think of it as an
artistic medium when we actually look at
how paints work they are deeply
technical there are all sorts of
different types of paints that have
different effects that cure differently
they have different textures different
material properties there's different
ways that you mix them different ways to
be aged I mean there's like science
behind paint there's a lot of technology
behind paints and this is true of most
art that's out there there's quite a bit
of technology and people who create art
are really good at their craft are
really good at the technology of their
arts but there's still a difference you
know we do classify these as different
things for a reason and so like why is
that
so the question of what is art how do we
define art that's one of those questions
that sort of puzzled philosophers for
pretty much all of human history and I
don't have a it's claimed to have an
answer to that question in its entirety
but I do have one small claim to make
just sort of about it
the edges what I would say about art is
that our we create art by using
technology to express emotional truth
and this is what separates art from the
typical ways that we use technology and
what we think of as technology because
in the case of technology or in our case
what we think of technology as is really
we're thinking about products you know
we're thinking about using technology to
create a product usually with the
intention of generating profit or
perhaps users that in theory according
some very magic silicon value math
generates revenue which doesn't actually
but you know we still have this concept
of revenue at the end of the day that
drives it and with art there isn't
really that concept
our business is a weird thing we're
gonna set that aside for the moments but
with art we're not trying to create
revenue that's not our intention our
intention is to express some truth about
you know ourselves about our society or
about the world you know it's kind of an
inward look in taking it out and we use
technology to express this thing to
other people outside for what is inside
of ourselves and so the way we do that
though is we first got a master our
craft we have to understand the basics
of what we do and so for LED aren't
specific like we see this little piece
here there is some technology that goes
behind it and so the first thing I want
to talk about I won't talk about how we
can create visualizations that look kind
of like this and we have to start by
talking about color and color spaces and
specifically I want to talk about the
HSV color space which is the hue
saturation value so the acronym stands
for color space this is very similar to
one you might have seen in the web
called HS l or hue saturation luminance
they're actually almost exactly the same
thing there's just a tiny little
difference to them but this is actually
pretty important for understanding color
and especially for doing art with it and
so explain why we need that first let's
talk about RGB so I think we all know
what RGB is red green blue
you know we express colors in the RGB
space in terms of how much red isn't it
how much green and how much blue and
these colors sort of add together to
create some color and we use this model
because RGB is McCain
nicholae how we create color and how we
work with color with various visual
devices so for example with these LEDs
the way we create a color LED you know a
specific color in here so there's
actually three LEDs embedded in it one
that is red green and blue and we change
how bright those various three are to
create any color same thing with LCD
screens projectors and basically
anything else we can think of that
creates a visual device and in fact the
oldest RGB device is our eyes themselves
so in our eyes we have three nerves
that's our light-sensitive and they're
specifically sensitive to very a
relatively narrow ranges of light one
towards green one towards red and one
towards blue and so RGB is really
important and that we use it for color
production and color sensing like it's a
mechanical thing but it's not how we
think about color like we look at my
pants I don't look at this and see like
oh I see equal amounts of red green and
blue no that's that's not what I'm
thinking I see white right we just don't
think about color in terms of RGB so
this is where HSV is really really
useful because HSV expresses how we
think about color so to illustrate that
let's talk about it
a little bit let's talk about hue first
so hue is kind of like the base color in
a lot of ways and we measure this in
degrees from 0 to 360 there's some
mathematical reasons some grass polar
coordinates whatever we're not going to
talk about that but just know that this
represents sort of the spectrum of color
and it actually Maps pretty closely to
these spectrums of visible light across
wavelengths like when we use you know a
prism to split of color the colors that
we get there are really similar to the
colors we get from the hue here same
thing when we see a rainbow so we can
start at zero degrees and at 360 degrees
by the way it's the same as zero degrees
because circle and we get a red color
but then we go in and we start to shift
the hue around a little bit and we can
see the color changes you know we've
gone up a little bit that's not great
and so like we get a little bit of a
color there we can shift it further we
get a blue color we kind of go further
we get a purple and then eventually we
come back around to red
and so this is what cute is it's sort of
like a base color sort of a primary
color in a lot of ways so the next up we
have saturation and saturation is kind
of like basically how washed out is this
color if you've ever done any sort of
image editing using like Photoshop or
Lightroom you'll notice as a saturation
slider usually you bump that up to make
it more colorful well this is exactly
what it's doing under the hood is it's
messing with this part of the color
space and so at a hundred percent you
know saturation is measured from zero to
100% 100% this is like full color this
is as much as much colors you can get
your here we have this sort of like fire
engine red kind of color well so we
start to drop that down we see it
getting just a little lighter it starts
to turn into sort of a pinkish it's not
really a vibrant red anymore it's like
lacking vibrancy and we keep going all
the way to zero and eventually we end up
with white there's a complete lack of
color in fact taking the saturation to
zero and any color will give us white as
it turns out now similar to saturation
is then value and it's sort of it's
actually mathematically related again
we're not gonna talk of the matte too
much but we can think of value is how
bright is the color so again we have
this really bright colored red but as we
start to drop this value from 100% to
zero we see it just getting dimmer and
we're starting to get sort of a maroon
color at about 50% when we take it all
the way and then we can get to black and
so these are the three channels that
make up hue saturation value color space
so we put it together we can create
anything we want so let's say we want to
create like a lilac sort of color you
know that light purple obscene has
purple my hair is purple I love purple
so purple
I just haven't remember is kind of over
here but even if I didn't remember where
purple was you know there's not that
much to go through you could just sort
of mess with the slider find the color
you want and we know that this is the
base color but this isn't a light like
like a lilac is a fairly washed out
color so now that tells me we need to
drop the saturation on it so we'll take
the saturation and we'll just put it
over here and thus we have a lilac color
so we've got that we mess with you in
saturation but the next thing we can do
is we can just make it you know darker
if we want to we can make it dimmer
let's say we're having to color themes
for a site we're doing a light and a
dark so the cool thing about the HSV
color space is we can take different
colors make them brighter or darker but
they kind of say the same color like we
look at this it's dark colored but
visually oh yeah that's the same thing
is this like they're super super related
and all I'm doing is changing one number
where as an RGB we have to change all
three we don't really know what the
relationship is like to get to this
color an RGB I would just have to
experiment like I have no idea what this
is in RGB because we can't reason about
RGB but we can about HSV and so this is
a great thing like HSV color space
provides a really great sort of
foundation to start doing any sort of
color work in art especially but even a
products do though HSV is sort of a
universally useful color space I think
but that alone isn't enough to give us
an animation so how do we get to
something like that well this is where
we do a little bit of math now not
particularly complicated math this is
like middle school trig level we're not
talking about like advanced calculus or
anything but so we'll do a review
because you know middle school was a
long time ago all right so it turns out
we can do all kinds of animation using
sine waves and this is the full formula
for a sine wave sometimes we see a
breviary one but this is actually all of
it there are a couple of parameters we
have a function you know f of T this is
sort of our output we're saying we have
some output that is a function of some
variable that's an input for now we're
seeing to keep it abstract wouldn't call
it T but this could be a distance you
know it could be you know we pass it and
say the value 0 for the first led 1 for
the next 2 for the you know and so on
and so forth you know this is it's a
function argument just like we have in
code and so then the output is going to
be a times the sine of Omega T plus V
plus B all right so what are all of
these different
variables to well first let's start with
Omega so Omega is what's called the
angular frequency which sounds kind of
technical but essentially what that
means is like how fast are slow is our
sine wave so right now we have an Omega
value of 1 but if we go and we messed
that we start to increase we can see our
sine wave starts to get busier you know
it just starts getting faster and faster
so next up we have fee this is the other
part that's inside of the sine wave and
this is essentially an offset it's what
it tells us where does the sine wave
start so you can see we mess with this
and we can just see that sine wave sort
of sliding around on the screen a bit
now in practice I don't actually use fee
myself but I want to include it for
completeness sake then next up we have a
which is sort of like a scaling factor
for the sine wave you know right now
this is going from negative 1 to 1 but
if we drop this to you say 0.5 we can
see this gets a little thinner and it's
just it's not as tall of a sine wave and
then last step we have B and this is
sort of a final offset like a constant
offset and this allows us to shift our
sine wave around the graph like this and
so with these parameters we can combine
them to create all kinds of stuff now
there are some interesting things that
happen as sort of the edges sort of the
edge cases to this so for example you
know to get this up a bit let's say we
drop our angular frequency all the way
to 0 so we do that you know it's like
it's getting slower and slower
eventually we just get a straight line
and this can be useful if we ever need
to do something constant or unchanging
by the way there's another way that we
can achieve this too though we can also
take a you know that scaling factor the
sine wave and drop it to zero and we
also get a straight line and so once we
have done that we get this straight line
we can use B to increase or decrease how
strong it is so you can think of as B is
like sort of an overall brightness for a
constant and a is an overall brightness
for the part that changes so how does
this map to LEDs and color spaces
well basically like this so in here we
have that exact same formula except now
instead of f of T I say color value of X
so what this is saying is we have some
color and when I say that the value the
value channel in HSV that value that
channel we're gonna set it based on the
sine wave and it's give me a function of
X which is distance again is which LED
are we talking about here so we can see
at the bottom we have kind of what the
LED output looks like when we vary the
value across distance according to a
sine wave and by the way the software
that is powering the LEDs on the screen
a lot of it's shared with the software
on here so we're kind of saying the same
thing by the way web but somebody is
really fun and really hard so we can go
in and we can change the angular
frequency according to distance and if
we increase this we see we start to keep
these like tiny little waves like almost
just a couple of dots but then as we
spread it out you know we can see them
getting longer and longer and eventually
we end up with just a flat line now
there's still a little bit of color here
you might be wondering why that is also
a perfect sine wave this is essentially
like floating point math you know these
are floating point numbers between
negative 1 and 1 but a color space
including HSV at least the way I did it
you know we have evaluate this between
zero and 100% which under the hood is
represented as zero to 255
just like RGB so we have to map those so
the way I set this up is so that
negative one is equal to zero percent
and positive one is equal to on a
percent so right now we're at basically
about 50% brightness and it's a flat
line so we can now use B to make this
bright you know about as bright as it
can get and then we can also turn it
completely off all right added some
weird threshold unless we can still do
all of this kind of work we can control
how the LEDs work in across distance and
we can also make it uniform now what if
we decided set value as a function of
some other variable like I mentioned
distance is one but we could do it for
something else so let's take it and make
it a function of time
so it would time we get something that
looks like this we can see I have where
the current marker and time is shifting
across the graph again positive one is a
hundred percent negative one is zero we
can see how we just get this lovely
fading in and out sort of animation
again just it's a sign value and we can
change this just like we did before
we'll increase the angular frequency and
we get something that's flashing really
fast so when I look at something like
this I'm kind of thinking like this kind
of makes me think of an emergency
warning light this is sort of an intense
animation you know it's a it's a little
bit anxiety producing it sort of in your
face so you know we can use these
mathematical parameters to evoke an
emotional mood you know we could think
about light in the way it's used
throughout our society we have these
correlations you know fast flashing red
like that is that's a warning sign so I
can evoke a little bit of a mood just by
sending a couple of sine wave parameters
conversely I can also slow this way down
and so this is like just very slowly
changing over time and if I picked
another color say then you know this
could be a very calming it's an almost
almost like it's sort of breathing a
little bit so we can evoke a different
mood by just changing the rate on this
we can affect this and do you even more
complicated things we could drop a to
say half and B we can bump up so that's
sitting up top like that and here we go
to full brightness with a little bit of
clipping let me drop that a bit and then
down to like half so it never gets fully
dark but we could still see it changing
and just sort of morphing a little bit
over time now what if we made this a
function about time and space turns out
we can do that with this modification of
the formula here so now you know we've
added a little bit more to the sine wave
we have Omega T times T plus Omega x
times X plus fee so we just added that a
little bit we sort of combined to the
previous two formulas together and by
doing that we get this row
wave pattern so at this you can start to
see kind of how this is being assembled
in this art piece here so again we can
slow this down and you can just it's
just barely moving across again this is
a very kind of soothing slow sort of
animation we can also make it go really
fast so it's just kind of zipping across
now what's interesting here though is
because this doesn't totally go away we
always see some light it's a little bit
of a different mood than we had on the
previous in which we were flashing it
really fast it's not quite that you know
warning warning kind of feeling to me
this just feels more like energy and
movement so again by though speaking of
us around we can still get you know
slightly different emotional feelings
out of it and we can also you know so
that's changing how fast is we can also
change this distance and change again
like are they little things and we can
string this down to this speed and now
it kind of makes me think of like ants
marching along or something like that so
you can get some like really fun stuff
just by you know again tweaking some
mathematical parameters so alright
that's how we edit the value channel and
that's kind of what we can do when we
were playing with the value what about
the other channels well saturation again
is very closely related to value and
practice this is sort of an inverse so
here we can see it's fading from red all
the way down to white and same thing we
can make this fade really fast or slow
we can also give it have it changes over
distance and again we get this sort of
like roving wave pattern that we saw
before it's just you know slightly it's
a different way of doing it
mathematically and gives a different
effect but we can still do that and we
can also do things like drop that down
bump this up so now we have it going
from red to pink it's like this could be
a great one to do say like on
Valentine's Day if you happen to
celebrate that there's no one get that
like red pink sort of motif going on so
we can start to get different types of
colors and things going on again just by
tweaking these parameters all right so
you saw hue it's alright we saw a
saturation in value but what about hue
so he was different it's less related we
a different effect so I want to start
here we have everything set to zero
uncle Mega Tina may make X so nothing is
changing over time and we had be set to
in the middle so the way this is mapped
by the way is 0 degrees is negative 1
and 360 degrees is positive 1 so right
now we're sitting at 0 which is right in
the middle it's 180 degrees which is
this light blue color so we can adjust B
and we'll see it just shifting across
the heat like we saw before again
there's some weird scaling I have with
be just negative numbers are weird with
my algorithm but we can kind of just set
this to a solid color just by changing
this B value in this equation so if we
want to just set a color this is how we
do it but then let's start to introduce
some variance over time let's just
increase this to 1 and we do that now we
see it just starting to slowly cycle
through the all the colors in an episode
this can be kind of an interesting
animation because you know we're just
getting this like changing sort of
vibrancy and we can make it go slow we
can make it go fast but then we can also
introduce some distance over time or we
make this a function of X and this is
where I think this gets the most unusual
as far as these equations go because
with this we get this sort of like
roving rainbow color and this can be a
pretty interesting one in and of itself
too because we're changing the hue over
time so it's like we're going around
that circle of hue all the way to the
end and again we can make that faster or
slower but what also gets interesting is
let's say we're gonna drop this down to
here and so what this is doing is sort
of clamping what part of the circle
we're on so you notice we don't have all
the colors anymore we're not going from
red all the way to red we're just sort
of sticking to like kind of right in the
middle or one part of the circle this is
gonna be I think maybe 120 to 180
like 240 degrees something like that so
we're taking like the slice of colors in
the middle and we can shift this up and
down so if you shift it down we're gonna
mostly see like some warmer coasts all
right again I have that word clipping
thing but we get up here to the top and
seen our in that
that blue mostly the blue purple side of
the spectrum so we can sort of clamp it
to certain ranges of colors and not get
all of the colors as well just by
tweaking a few more parameters and so
that's how the three color we can vary
the three colour channels to create
animations using sine waves however it
turns out in most cases there's usually
a fourth channel when we talk about
color spaces we pretty much talk about
three channels RGB we talk about three
but in practice we always use four and
the fourth one is alpha or transparency
you know we have to talk about using the
RGB a spectrum or red green blue alpha
well we can do the same thing in the HSV
color space or we can do HSV a hue
saturation value and alpha so we can add
transparency to these and so here on
this next slide I'm doing exactly that
in this case is a black background so
this looks exactly like we saw with
value I can take the parameters and we
get the same thing we saw when we were
tweaking value but this is transparent
so it means we can put a layer
underneath it we can start doing layers
we can like composite layers together
and we can bring in multiple waves so I
didn't put all the controls on here
because it would've been a lot but we
have the full controls for the Alpha
channel on the top layer and I just have
B on the bottom so we had this roving
wave and again you know we can make it
faster or slower we can change the
distance and now I'm gonna bring in the
bottom layer which the bottom layer by
the way I have a hue of 180 degrees
which again is that teal color so as we
bring this in we start to see we get a
little bit of blue mixed under the red
so with this we have now I have two
separate colors we have two completely
separate waves doing their own thing
layered in together so by the way the
full set of equations running on this
looks kind of like that it's a lot I
know it's hard to read I don't like
looking at it so let's look at some code
instead let's just think about it
represented like this and like this okay
this is a little more what we're using
this is a little friendlier looking like
I could do this so in this case it's
it's an array of colors
but except instead of saying q2 a
constant we're setting it to a function
we can tweak those parameters and then
we can layer them together and so when
we look at this piece right here for
example there are actually three layers
going on the very bottom layer is just a
solid blue color it never changed this
is just sitting there being blue and
then on top of that there's another
layer that is set to green but what I'm
doing with that is I'm varying the Alpha
over time there's nothing but distance
so it's just going from like fully
opaque green across the entire strip to
fully transparent green so we get this
sort of fading from blue to green and
when you look at you can actually kind
of see the color in there but then on
top of that then I have that sort of
roving wave pattern we saw in red that
makes it look like it's going over and
it's how I created that animation the
system I used to do this it's a little
bit complex you can talk to me later but
we can do all of this from JavaScript
this is like one of the really cool
things about like johnny-five and no
BOTS and that whole world is that we can
write some code that looks like this so
we can bring it as a library called node
pixel written by Ajay Fisher who I think
is sitting over there somewhere and then
we're taking in johnny-five which
there's a number of us collaborators
here on and then this library called RVL
node animations which I myself wrote
it's kind of some of the stuff running
out here we just sort of mix them
together and most of code is
initialization you know it's importing
libraries it's getting the board ready
initializing this strip but then inside
kind of inside that radio vent that's
what we're just gonna go set some colors
we're gonna create a layer we're using a
look I created a little helper method
because sometimes I don't want to use
those coefficients directly so we can
like just kind of create an animation we
create a layer then we can posit that
into a whole set of wave parameters
which I'd have a little helper method
for and if finally we can render from
the way parameters you know all those
sine waves into a list of RGB pixels and
then finally we can go and set each
pixel and our LED using a node pixel and
so with this code like this code right
here is functional at least I think it
is I didn't test it what could I say
but like this should be functional
JavaScript code right here a few bugs
aside and like that's not very much code
to get something like this going
like this is the thing that I love about
JavaScript and why this is so powerful
is that once we had this in JavaScript
once we're inside of node which is where
this is running that opens up all of the
web to us specifically we can do
something like this now in this case the
screen that we see here isn't quite
synchronized I think I can do this so
most of this the slides were synced this
specific page not all right I can't show
you that's ok but there's a node server
running on the Raspberry Pi that I have
kind of hidden behind here which is
ultimately controlling this piece right
here and this is its control panel this
is a web app you know you could load
this up on your mobile phone if you're
connected to the right Wi-Fi network so
we can go in here and we have this one
animation but let's just set it to
rainbow so now we have we can see a
cycling through the hue and that's also
like I think a nice animation as well we
can make it go really fast like you know
it's just really chugging along and then
just controlling this from a web
application we can go there's just like
pulsing a color we get that breathing
effect which I kind of like this one
myself we can just cycle through colors
as well like you know we have this now
in a web application it's open to the
Internet and once we have this we can
like bring people in you know we can
create art pieces that encourage other
people to come and interact with it like
this is a lot of things I think is so
exciting about a lot of art coming out
these days is that it's interactive it
encourages people to engage with it and
explore with it
and I think there's a lot of really
profound ways that we can you know
create experiences for people and so the
thing I kind of a come back to the end
is like where this is all about doing
art and I really want to encourage all
of you to express yourself like art is
really really important and I think that
art is the single greatest thing our
species has ever created ever like I
think art is what makes us so unique and
I think it represents the best side of
us and so I really encourage all of you
to try it out you know we have these
skills we have these technology skills
if we just kind of rethink how we're
gonna use them we can start using it to
create art think about art and one of
the reasons I think it's so important
though is it's about expressing
emotional truth and to do that we have
to understand ourselves in order to
express what we are feeling through art
we first have to know what we are
feeling and that may sound like a
tautology or something simple but it's
actually difficult it takes
introspection and that's really really
important because it makes us better
people like when we know who we really
are when we know how we engage with the
world how we fit in the world that
enables us to then start interacting
with the world in a better way it allows
us to be more honest allows us to be
authentic to be our true selves and
that's hugely important it's better for
us as individuals it's better in our
relationships and it allows us to create
art so if there's one thing I want to
leave all of you with today is to think
about how can you feed your inner artist
and not just feed capitalism
[Applause]
[Music]